if your entire world was suddenly
destroyed by horrifying god-like
creatures what would you do everyone you
love is dying and no one can save you
i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the titans an attack on titan this kid
is about to lose everything and this
town has no idea that everyone is about
to be eaten by horrifying flesh-eating
monsters erin here is a small town kid
growing up inside the walled city
district of shiganshina with these
massive walls designed to protect
humanity from the terrifying threats
that lurk right outside known as the
titans aaron and his childhood friend
mikasa finish up collecting wood and
head back home but then they encounter a
group of city guards a branch of the
city's military tasked with the defense
of the city walls however they're all
drunk on the job and this angers aaron
who demands that they stand guard and do
what they're paid for protect the city
from the horrifying titans who could
show up at any moment to kill everyone
the guards however laugh at the two kids
saying that there hasn't been an attack
on any city in over a hundred years so
they can chill out but these guards
don't realize that aaron's fears are
about to come true it's only a matter of
time before humanity's worst threat
comes back for blood okay first off
these guards are idiots these titans
have been stalking the earth and this
city for over a hundred years humanity
is living in a bubble that can burst at
any moment walling ourselves off is only
putting a band-aid over two gigantic
problems and one of those is right
outside of the walls and the second is
within starvation by walling off
humanity we've created a food problem
pushing off and delaying the massive
titan threat is going to lead to them
becoming greater in numbers until
eventually and probably already have the
titans outnumber humans this choice
humanity has made is going to lead down
a series of events that will result in
the death of hundreds if not thousands
of innocent people as far as we know
right now the titans look like humans
which might lead us to believe that they
reproduce in the exact same way however
since there haven't been any sightings
of titan babies and the titans don't
seem to have any male or female organs
there might be some other way they're
reproducing that we're not aware of
however regardless of the traits unique
to the titans the physiology is
extremely similar meaning the same
physiological principles should apply to
them regardless of size either way our
main goal is to destroy every last titan
so that way there's no possibility
they'll ever come back it's easier said
than done but at least we know that it's
a possibility as far as we know now the
titans aren't capable of critical
thinking meaning that they lack the
ability to properly assess a situation
like a human would the most important
way of beating a creature much bigger
and stronger than you is to understand
both its strengths and weaknesses this
should come in handy in the near future
and it's going to provide a lot of
opportunities to outsmart the creatures
when needed and speaking of outsmarting
creatures i would begin to invest time
and money into research and development
for aircraft vehicles this is going to
grant us the ability of aerial
reconnaissance now the 3d maneuver gear
is a great way to traverse the city but
outside it's completely useless unless
you're surrounded by trees not only that
the gear can only take you so far into
the air while an airplane or dare i say
a balloon should be able to propel you
far enough into the air that the titans
can't attack you the time between titan
attacks was around 100 years and based
on the clothing and overall appearance
of the city it resembles something close
to early 1900s germany so in theory the
engineers that live in the city should
be advanced enough to have come up with
something similar if not exactly the
same as the first plane to ever be made
it would allow the city to check for the
incoming threat of titans and allow the
guards of the city to either lure the
titans away from the city or attack them
head on outside of the city walls that's
when they get word that the city's most
skilled warriors the scout regiment is
back from their titan hunt aaron drags
mikasa to see his beloved heroes come
back but they quickly realize that being
a hero is costly expecting something out
of a fairy tale he instead sees the men
and women of the scout regiment broken
bruised and heavily traumatized by their
journey outside of the walls back at
home aaron speaks about how he wants to
grow up to slay titans but his mom
thinks otherwise she gets mad at him for
even suggesting the idea aaron's dad
then gets up to leave for work but not
before he reveals a key to a secret
basement and tells aaron that when he
gets back he'll show him what's down
there but aaron has no idea the insanity
that awaits him down in that basement
later on aaron sits with mikasa and his
best friend armin dreaming of a life
beyond these walls and what adventures
await him beyond this town and that's
when their lives change forever suddenly
the whole town hears it a flash and
rumble hits over the city walls
everybody goes to check it out and
realizes something is terribly wrong
they have no idea that they're about to
witness the most horrifying thing that
they've ever seen before a site that
nobody has seen in over a hundred years
a ginormous hand reaches over the walls
it's a titan and it blasts through the
city walls reigniting storms and
hellfire upon everybody in shiganshina
city this 60-foot titan is an
unstoppable force it tears through the
walled gates unleashing an army of
smaller titans right behind it citizens
begin dying left and right men women and
children are wiped out in seconds no one
is safe from these bloodthirsty titans
as chaos reigns in the city aaron looks
on in horror as he sees his house
destroyed at the feet of the titans he
rushes to check on his mother and finds
her trapped in the rubble but at that
moment a titan spots them and begins to
make its way towards them eren is about
to be crushed along with his mother
until suddenly a familiar face shows up
this blonde guy who is ordered by the
mother to save her children and leave
her behind looking at his mother's sweet
face one last time aaron and mikasa are
dragged from their homes as this blonde
guy carries them away helpless aaron can
do nothing but look in horror as his
mother is picked up and is devoured by
the titan okay if i was aaron right now
i would be [ __ ] my pants after
hearing about titans for a hundred years
learning about them in school and
fearing their arrival that day has
finally come now the first thing to do
would be to start running for cover we
don't know much about the titans but
what we do know is that if we're
targeted by any of them it's game over
also the massive amounts of flying
debris caused by the titans is going to
be something we need to be extremely
careful for we need to treat this like a
real life survival situation if we're
going to make it out of here a lie
luckily for us this city is densely
packed leaving a lot of blind spots
where nobody can see us and while it
might seem like a brutal decision we
need to leave our mom behind right where
she is because our house is on an
elevated area meaning that it'll be
easier for the titans to see us there
either way her legs are completely
crushed and there's no way that two kids
can carry a fully grown adult around and
we can clearly see she's going to need
medical attention which isn't going to
be possible with the current situation
now even though it might seem like a
good idea to find out where the rest of
the citizens went there's only one
emergency entrance out of shiganshina
which means everyone will be running
towards the same direction which would
increase our chances of being spotted by
the titans i would say that's a bad plan
it would be a good idea to carefully
make our way into a house near the walls
of shiganshina and stay there for the
time being everybody's already rushed
out of their houses meaning there should
be enough food and resources for us to
sustain ourselves for at least a few
days until we can wait it out as far as
we know the titans are simple-minded
creatures meaning they'll likely walk
out of the city if they don't manage to
find any humans for an extended period
of time and also they're far too big to
easily take a sneak peek into any of the
houses or dare i say even the basement
of the houses so we'll be safe there for
the time being countless citizens flee
to the escape boats that lay nearby as
eren and mikasa join them sailing away
further deep into human territory but
back at the gate it's a bloodbath blonde
guy here stands with the other soldiers
who do their best to contain the damage
they fire the cannons everywhere and the
titans slowly overpower the humans
limited technology making a mockery of
it causing some of the guards to panic
and flee their post and sprint to the
next gate to shut it for good because
these soldiers know what we're thinking
that if they don't get inside the next
wall if they don't close this gate they
will all die but that's when they see it
the feet of another massive muscle-bound
titan who begins charging directly at
the gate with full force no man-made
weapon can stop the titan and so the
guards run for their lives as it blasts
through the gate nothing can stop this
okay if we've been forced into tiny
walled off cities due to gigantic
creatures roaming right outside of our
doorstep we should be well prepared to
take them head on with the tools at our
disposal now everyone in this city knows
that this day was going to come sooner
or later even though the walls are
pretty high it's only a band-aid option
to the outside threat because if even
one titan spots evidence of human life
around the walls it's all over however
not a single person in the city was
prepared for this moment which is about
to get hundreds if not thousands of
people killed now this would require
some prior thinking but hear me out the
city's designers should have built the
city in a way that wasn't so obvious
from the outside even though we don't
know exactly how the creatures think if
i was a titan roaming the wilderness
then i might have done a double take
seeing a massive concrete wall bigger
than myself we clearly know that there
are basements built in the city because
aaron's house already has one in a way
the city government should have prepared
for this by making it so every single
house in the city has some sort of
underground basement or bunker however
it's not a foolproof idea especially if
your house is trampled on by a titan you
might have some issues getting out of
the basement with all of the debris
blocking the way out but either way
being stuck underground is better than
being dead while this might not be the
easiest situation to deal with the first
thing the city guards should have done
would have been to keep the titans from
getting past the city walls considering
that all of humanity as we know it is
contained within this little city they
should have probably tried to avoid
having any of it destroyed since it
likely took decades of logistical work
to get it up and running and the
resources of the land around them can't
sustain them forever as the hours pass
news of the fall of shiganshina on the
south side of walmaria reaches all the
other territories after 100 years the
titans have finally begun to attack
mankind once again and within that year
all of humanity is forced to withdraw
behind the second wall wall rose
thousands lay dead and aaron is
devastated from the traumatic events
that just happened infused with rage he
then vows to destroy the monsters who
took his mother from him the titans
themselves so with his budding
relationship with armin and the watchful
mikasa they joined the cadet corps
training school in order to one day rid
the world of this titan threat over the
next three years aaron armin and mikasa
train like their lives depend on it and
as the months pass the three are tested
to their limits learning the true nature
of what it takes to become humanity's
greatest weapon against the titans as
aaron learns that he's pretty bad at
everything but is helped to suck a
little bit less by his close friend
badass annie leonhart who knows a little
bit more about combat than all the other
recruits who try their best to get
through their hellish training aaron and
his crew find out that not many people
have first-hand experience of seeing
what the titans are capable of hell some
of them have just joined up to look cool
most of them have no idea of what
horrors await them in the coming days
months and years except for an unlucky
few the group finds out that most of the
kids here are really here just for show
to live up to society's expectations
with little idea of what is really going
on some signed up to simply join the
easiest and safest branch of them all
the military police where they are
tasked with doing little other than
guarding the king himself this is what
humanity is counting on these kiddos
humanity right now is doing a terrible
job of preparing these kids for what's
to come doing basic fitness tests is a
good way to tell if they're physically
tough enough to handle a titan threat
but preparing them mentally is a whole
other challenge only a few years earlier
the titans came through and destroyed
half of the city and it's going to
happen again very soon while making sure
the recruits are safe this is going to
lead them to a false sense of security
that won't last forever it's important
to note that the army makes sure that
the kids know what's coming and the best
way to do that is to show them the
threat that they're dealing with head on
if i were working for the army in this
city i would propose that every student
form a group at the end of their
training for one final test witness a
titan in the flesh this may be extreme i
know but is this kind of rigorous
training that would benefit the rest of
the army the most and show these kids
what these monsters truly are this would
instill fear into the recruits and make
sure that they're never lazing around on
the job unlike these guys getting drunk
and playing games in addition it might
be helpful to teach every citizen in the
city how to act when an emergency
situation arises a mandatory military
conscription would be a good way to
harden the citizens up to the harsh
realities of the world they're in many
countries in the world like south korea
and singapore promote this very same
idea to keep their citizens ready in
time of war this also might include
familiarizing every single person with
the omni-directional gear since that's
the only known method of slaying a titan
there's strength in numbers and the city
needs all the strength it can get the
cadets finally graduate and are given
the options of joining three different
military branches the garrison regiment
tasked with reinforcing the walls and
protecting the city the military police
regiment which serves to protect the
king and maintain order and finally the
most dangerous group of all the scout
regiment which are tasked with surveying
the dangerous titan territories outside
of the city and one where lives are
routinely lost knowing the fate of the
world rests mainly upon one group aaron
mikasa and armin decide to join the
scout regiment the group begins their
daily life as humanity's top defenders
and for a while everything seems like
it's going to be okay but nothing lasts
forever and on one fateful day the
horrors return yet again suddenly a
lightning strike erupts in front of the
tross gate bringing with it another
titan right in front of aaron himself a
massive explosion erupts in front of the
scout regiment sending tons of young
soldiers to their death in seconds aaron
holds on with his grappling hook for his
sweet life as he and everyone else sees
now the gaping hole right within the
giant wall itself the titan invasion is
happening again the mass of titan bats
the wall mounted cannons away in one
swift motion forcing everyone to head
for the gate entrance but something is
up and aaron notices that this titan
went for their defenses immediately and
knew which part of the wall to hit these
monsters are intelligent erin goes on
the offensive and rides up the massive
monolith of a titan and tries to kill it
at its weak spot but suddenly the titan
disappears and now the city must seal
off the entrance before more smaller
titans get in the city prepares for
another attack as everyone runs inward
through the next gate and the city
forces put up defenses and lie in wait
because if the titans get through this
route it'll be just like what happens
before they must hold off the titans and
they need to seal off that 8 meter hole
if they don't all want to die right here
and now humanity begins to arm itself
and readies for the incoming fight as
chaos reigns throughout the streets
right at the very heart of humanity lies
the king and this military general and
badass bald guy they then receive word
that the trust wall has been broken into
so bald guy like the stud that he is
prepares to go help his men but the king
forbids him to leave arguing instead to
stay here to protect the royal castle
with the king not giving one [ __ ] how
many people die for him but bald guy is
a bald stud and ignores the king himself
and goes to ready himself for the
bloodiest battle his generation will
ever face back within the tross district
at the inner second wall wall rose aaron
and his regiment are given the orders by
the garrison regiment for battle plans
to help save the city because all the
advanced teams at this moment have been
wiped out which means aaron and his
group must hold their ground against the
fiercest beasts this world has ever
known the titans because if they don't
do it then no one will okay here we go
again now all that training that the
recruits didn't do is about to come back
full circle however it's too late now to
go back into the past and train everyone
properly so we have to make use of what
we have right now the first thing we
need to accept is that people are
probably going to die but as long as it
isn't us it's okay with the group that
we have right now it's in our best
interest to take the times on one by one
because splitting the teams up is only
going to make it harder for us to take
out the titans and in doing so it's
going to increase the amount of time
that the titans have to wreck the city
and eat innocent civilians the best way
to deal with them is to isolate them
first and make sure the titans don't
surround us they're absolutely gigantic
so as long as we keep our heads about us
it shouldn't be too hard to avoid any
surprise attacks and due to the titan's
limited cognitive abilities we should be
able to get an edge on them by using
multiple people to distract them while
someone else aims for the back of the
neck because while these times look like
slow-moving creatures they seem to have
the ability to defy the laws of physics
moving much faster than any creature
that size should be able to this means
not only are they extremely dangerous
but they're extremely unpredictable as
well for us we need to reduce that
unpredictability as much as possible
aaron and armin wait for the titans to
reach their location as they talk about
defeating the titans right here and now
and shooting up to the very top of their
ranks within the regiment but aaron has
no idea just how difficult that is going
to be the rest of aaron and armin's
squad group 34 shows up just as they see
the incoming titans let the battle begin
the gang then charges forward hurtling
through the sky and heading straight
towards the titan but suddenly another
titan flies up right in front of them
and catches one of aaron's teammates in
his mouth and it swallows him right in
front of all of aaron's friends the
horrified gang is frozen in shock as
they watch their friend classmate and
squad member die right in front of them
this enrages aaron who charges forward
at that very same time hurtling through
the sky until snap a titan bites his leg
off causing him to crash on a nearby
roof armin does nothing but watches
impure terror as all of his squad mates
are picked off one by one by the titans
it's a bloodbath but he's too paralyzed
with fear to move a muscle and just then
another nearby titan picks up a
petrified armor and is ready to devour
him whole but aaron quickly gets up the
last bit of his strength and saves him
pulling him out and away from the mouth
of the titan holding the titan's mouth
open until the titan clamps his mouth
shut this went way worse than we could
have possibly imagined and this group
messed up big time not to put the blame
on one person but aaron royally screwed
up this time around he got too emotional
and that was his biggest mistake this
guy had it out for the titans since day
one and why wouldn't he they killed his
mom right in front of him and destroyed
his childhood home it makes me wonder
though similar to joining the military i
wonder if the cadet corps has any sort
of psychiatric requirement for entry
because his disdain for these monsters
while handy is what caused his downfall
not addressing emotional wounds from a
traumatic past in most cases will almost
always get worse over time and frankly
i'm surprised that aaron hasn't resorted
to coping with alcoholism or food at
this point seeing his fellow teammate
get eaten was the last straw for him and
this is what ultimately caused him to
lash out in rage and ignore the group
dynamic and make a plan that could have
prevented him and all of his teammates
from getting eaten to begin with and i
cannot emphasize how much he screwed up
but this little incident is going to be
the best and worst mistake he's ever
made armin the only survivor of squad 34
snaps out of his day state and runs off
unsure of himself and the rest of the
world's fate because it's not looking
good as people and members of the
regiment try and escape with fear and
uncertainty leading the way just as they
see this one titan come straight for
them but luckily for them more regimen
members along with mikasa come and cut
the titan down forcing its corpse to
crash right in front of the terrified
citizens the public finally gets a leg
up on the evacuation and all the
regiments are forced to retreat but
mikasa opts to help out more of the
trapped soldiers in the nearby buildings
crawling with titans but on the way
there they encounter soldiers who have
run out of jumping gas for their gear
thanks to the supply soldiers within the
headquarters being too scared to do
their job this means that the rest of
the soldiers outside can't scale the
wall to retreat which means they're
sitting ducks and it's only a matter of
time until more titans find them but
this one cadet ain't taking no [ __ ] at
what life throws at him and with few
other options demands that they attack
the headquarters so they can resupply
themselves with more gas at once and
mikasa joins in and convinces the squad
that they can do it and also spots a
sullen army who sits nearby defeated and
then mikasa learned that eren and the
entirety of the 34th squadron has been
wiped out causing her to reel back in
shock her only family left is dead
mikasa quickly recovers and states that
she will retake the headquarters with
them or without them and everyone is
shocked with how calloused and cold
mikasa is mikasand the group sets off
with what little gas they have left and
goes flying across the sky and armin
notices that mikasa is going too fast
and burning through her gas too much and
he realizes something she misses aaron
and is letting her emotions guide her
decisions but suddenly mikasa drops out
of the sky hitting the rooftop with a
bone-crunching thud she contemplates
giving up right then and there and with
the titans on her tail is about to get
eaten until another titan comes in
swinging beating this other titan
senseless and not trying to attack her
armin just then arrives in the neck of
time and picks up mikasa but mikasa
can't believe what she's seeing a titan
fighting another titan using human-like
movements to defeat this other monster
holy [ __ ] this is insane we're used to
seeing these monsters fighting but we
have to be scrupulous enough to always
pay attention to the little things i
want to point something out most titans
fight like that of some animal with
lower intelligence fighting like wild
animals swinging their arms and using
their teeth to bite as a form of offense
but this titan fights like someone with
a higher iq he isn't swinging his arms
is what i'm saying so mikasa and her
group need to calm down and get to the
bottom of this because whatever this new
kind of titan is all we know right now
is that it's absolutely terrifying
mikasa and armin said in shock but have
little time to react as the other
soldiers say they need to get to the
supply headquarters now but mikasa is
out of gas armin then gives mikasa his
equipment and has an idea if they take
out the nearby titans they can then lead
this seemingly human-like titan that
they've just discovered to the supply
headquarters the gang agrees and heads
out killing the other nearby titans and
aiding this one and leading it to the
supply hq as more and more regiment
members are killed they finally reach
the headquarters as the other members
hear from mikasa that they have an ally
on their side this raging titan the
group then prepares themselves with
weaponry and heads to the titan-filled
basement where all their supplies lie
waiting for them armin quickly devises a
plan and the soldiers prepare to blind
all the titans down there along with a
few extra soldiers to stay up hidden in
the scaffolding to surprise attack them
the team then huddles up in the lift and
descends down into hell itself with the
platform slowly lowering down until the
group finally lays eyes on the titans
luring them in step by step waiting for
the perfect moment until they fire
blinding the titans and allowing the
troops from the scaffolding to descend
from above and cut them down the gang
then resupplies their gas tanks and
prepares themselves for the ensuing
fight of a lifetime the squadron finally
begins to ascend the wall and get the
hell out of there but mikasa remains
behind as she and armand see their
mysterious titan ally getting
cannibalized by the other titans she
suggests that they save this titan and
some other members know better than to
pass on this incredible chance of a
lifetime to have a titan ally and they
offered to help mikasa and armin but
suddenly they see their titan break free
and kill every single other titan in the
area kicking ass and taking names until
it collapses surrounded by a field of
smoke but at that moment they see the
most insane thing ever a human body
breaks free from the back of this
titan's neck it's aaron mikus's eyes
bulge wide as she runs to go investigate
seeing a fully formed aaron with all of
his limbs intact elsewhere the elite
scouting team returns back to a swarm of
titans and they swiftly take them out
but this one guy then mentions that a
swarm of titans have begun moving
northward towards the main city forcing
the scouts to move back within the tross
district armin and mikasa try and help a
tired aaron back up to his feet but
they're not out of this [ __ ] just yet
because they've just made the biggest
mistake of their lives and it could cost
them everything suddenly surrounding the
group an entire regiment of soldiers aim
and draws their weapons ready to kill
aaron right here and now thinking he's a
titan in disguise which means mikasa and
armin by helping aaron have committed an
act of treason mikasa draws her sword
and is ready to kill anyone who tries to
kill aaron aaron pleads to everyone that
he's one of the good guys but no one
believes him and this bearded captain is
done listening so he orders to destroy
them right here and now with a blast
from a cannon at that moment mikasa
grabs aaron and armin and they try to
make a run for it but it's too late
suddenly the pull of mikasa grabbing
aaron makes his key flip out in front of
his face unlocking a memory of his death
telling him that if walmaria ever goes
down he needs to go find what's hidden
in the basement of his house aaron is
shocked to realize that his dad must
have drugged him and that the key is the
answer to all of this okay we have no
idea just what the hell happened but if
i were aaron i would try to be as
non-confrontational as possible at this
very moment this is a delicate situation
and acting with any kind of aggression
or desperation is likely to get us
killed i would tell mikasa here to stand
down and let me represent myself because
there's no way in hell that acting like
i did nothing wrong is going to work
from the perspective of the guards it's
only going to make us look like we're a
group of undercover titans working
together to get this city destroyed
people know that mikasa and erin have
been friends since they were kids so of
course she would want to come to aaron's
rescue no matter what the situation to
avoid looking like a suspicious piece of
[ __ ] i would calmly tell the dozens of
soldiers pointing their guns that we
have no idea just what the hell happened
honesty is key and any sign of foul play
is going to result in all of our instant
demise looking at it logically aaron was
swallowed by a titan meaning that he's
definitely not on their side that titan
was out to kill him just like any other
military force here however if he can
somehow turn into a titan this is
monumental they should be using aaron
for their own good because he was
clearly attacking other titans which
means that at a bare minimum he still
retained a bit of his consciousness
while in titan form aaron then remembers
everything that his dad tried to make
him forget biting his finger and
transforming yet again into a titan this
terrifies everyone as beard guy looks at
aaron in sheer horror thinking who the
hell is this guy aaron wakes up merged
with muscle tissue breaking free from
his titan creation meanwhile armin looks
at him in shock this isn't the errand
that he once knew this is something else
aaron then jumps down and meets up with
the two remembering his dad and the
basement he's the reason for all of this
mikasa then focuses on aaron as they
figure out a plan to get out of here but
aaron's nose is suddenly bleeding and
his face looks pale looks like being a
titan is taking its toll on him aaron
then tells the two that they shouldn't
try and help him but mikasa isn't having
any of it and neither is armin who steps
up and tries to convince the garrison
regiment just outside of the fog that he
is no threat but beard guy doesn't
believe him and is about to tell the
cannons to fire again until commander
bald guy stops witnessing the finest
soldier salute that armin has ever given
commander bald guy cuts the kids a break
because he believes them okay if i'm
going up against all the military
branches it's unlikely unless by some
act of god that we'd be able to convince
them that we're not a threat it may seem
counter-intuitive but our safest option
was running away if it wasn't for
commander bald guy there's already so
much we don't know about the titans like
where they come from hell we barely know
how to kill them if aaron didn't have
commander bald guy then i would have
seriously contemplated bolting the hell
out of there because not even our
titan-turning friend can explain to us
how he can turn into a titan yet
commander bald guy then takes him up on
the wall where he hears them out and
even armin shows he's cut out for
soldier's life by offering the best plan
that anyone has ever heard he tells the
commander that aaron in titan form can
lift up the big boulder stuck within the
town and fill the gaping hole at the
wrecked entrance which can in turn stop
all titans from re-entering finally
reclaiming the trost district the
commander agrees to go along with this
desperate plan and so does aaron however
whether he actually has the strength to
lift that rock or not is another
question the commander sets the plan in
motion luring away a majority of the
titus to one corner of the wall while
aaron tries to move the giant boulder to
the entrance without having to take on
any other titans and takes alongside him
an elite squad of soldiers to accompany
him this is a plan with a terrifyingly
high rate of failure and hundreds of
people will die everything and everyone
relies on this plan they all rely on
erin they cannot afford to mess this up
the commander convinces the terrified
masses to help on this one last mission
to stop the titans to save humanity and
humanity responds to his call and
rallies up to try and fight one more
time and so the plan begins with aaron
and his little squad running towards the
site of the giant boulder and aaron
finally transforms into his horrifying
titan state but something is not right
because aaron turns around and suddenly
tries to kill mikasa his best friend
aaron now in full rage mode continuously
tries to kill mikasa and she tries to
convince this titan that she's a part of
his family but this glasses guy sees the
plan backfire and fires the red flare up
into the sky confirming to everybody
that the plan has failed mikasa however
through her cunningness makes aaron
knock himself out whilst the other group
of soldiers now think of a new planet
but they don't have time to think
because two titans have just been
spotted nearby the group contemplates to
leave aaron here but mikasa thinks that
there's still hope back on the other
side of the wall the soldiers see the
red flare high up in the sky and think
their titan plan has failed forcing
armin to think fast and run off but
commander bald guy here tells the group
to hold because just like mikasa he
still has faith in eren back at the side
of the boulder mikasa convinces the team
to believe in ere forcing them to keep
the titans busy until they can recover
him but even more titans begin to show
up near aaron forcing the team to split
up and kick some ass but in the midst of
all of this armin gets near aaron and
tells him the situation not getting
anywhere armin takes out his sword and
slices right into where aaron's body is
stabbing his arm and waking him the hell
up and this time for the better aaron in
his titan form picks up the boulder and
begins walking towards the trost
entrance just as the garrison regiment
and the scout's regiment tag team all of
these titans circling nearby it's a
bloodbath but it gets the job done
allowing an exhausted aaron to finally
plug the hole and pass out armin then
comes to get aaron out of his titan body
right as the remaining titans inside the
wall try and attack them but just then
the best of the best comes in swinging
to save the day it's the elite scout
regiment saving the day and helping the
humans take out the remaining titans
gathered in bunches near the wall saving
trost for now later aaron wakes up bound
and caged with the scout regiment taking
responsibility for him and holding the
one thing that could save them all the
key to his father's basement okay hold
up these guys just took the most
valuable thing that we have right now if
i was aaron i would try to convince this
guy and the rest of the scout regiment
to look more into my father because it's
not that far-fetched to think that my
dad a scientist might have something to
do with my titan abilities it makes
sense logically that i was his first
human guinea pig a simple result of his
experiments because at this point they
won't get any more information out of me
since i don't know anything else they
should really save us both sometime and
look more into the man likely behind all
of this my scientist father himself but
now's not the time for saving the world
because the public then decides that
aaron will first have to fight his way
in court to see if he really belongs
with the humans or not but the scout
regiment unlike the rest wants to use
aaron to retake the wall outside of the
district of trust while maria but the
public doesn't trust aaron even one bit
so the scout regiment gets creative and
beats the [ __ ] out of him showing that
only the scout regiment can handle a
beast of this nature and so the court
agrees to hand him over to the best of
the best the scout regiment who planned
to take back walmaria by heading back to
aaron's hometown shigan china later on
the way there the gang stops over at an
old scout regiment post where aaron
comes face to face with some of the best
scouts in the world and these scouts are
not like the rest because unlike most of
society the scouts think aaron is too
viable to kill and they need to prove it
later at dinner aaron meets a mad
scientist or she might as well be this
glasses girl who asks aaron for help
with her experiments that she's running
on two captured titans experiments in
communication shielding titans from
sunlight what makes them less active
overall and finding out that they don't
need food or water to survive nor do
they breathe telling aaron that based on
what she found the only thing that
titans rely on is sunlight hey guys
griffin here just want to pop in really
quickly we want to be able to show you
each story in all of its full gory
details but we don't want to get flagged
we already had another video get flagged
so in order to fix that we're setting up
our very own patreon account it's going
to be set up very soon so keep an eye
out for updates glasses girl then goes
over all of her terrifying theories as
to who or what the titans are and talks
aaron's ear off the whole night until
morning comes and they find out that
someone has killed their test subjects
the doctor then loses her [ __ ] as they
try to figure out which person or group
of persons did this it seems like that
there's a traitor in the scout regiment
the scout regiment then conducts an
investigation into who exactly killed
these valuable titan test subjects as
captain of the scout squadron badass
captain levi grabs aaron and others to
join him on a scout mission just as
another higher up then announces to all
the young rookies that the scouts now
have open spots to join in their ranks
but while most of the peeps in the 104th
regiment decide to join the scouts annie
decides to join the military police in
spite of all of her other comrades the
higher-ups also convinced the rookies
that they now have a secret weapon to
beat the titans located in the home of
eren yeager's basement but in order to
get there they need to take back walmart
and take out all of the horrifying
titans that wait for them there and this
thought scares the hell out of the young
recruits and most end up walking away
leaving behind only a brave few willing
to take on the worthy cause little do
all these recruits know that many of
them will die soon enough over the
course of time the recruits begin
training for what will be the most
dangerous day of their lives learning
various combat and formation drills
until the fateful day arrives and the
scout regiment including aaron armin and
mikasa roll out to take back shiganshina
district and find the hidden secret
hidden within aaron's basement they
cross the plain lush terrain and they
carry out their formation distracting
titans left and right and allowing for
the various platoons to advance deeper
into enemy territory until they see one
titan headed straight for armin but this
titan is no ordinary titan it's
something far deadlier and one with
insane intelligence defeating this scout
here with ease with his eyes locked onto
armin in the distance it looks to be a
titan just like eren's a human titan the
female titan stomps at harmon on the
other side the titans have broken the
scout formation many scouts have been
eaten or killed the female titan slowly
goes to grab armin but instead she only
takes off his hood to check him out
before running away could this be the
human traitor the one who sabotaged the
scout's experiments from earlier okay
this changes everything if having aaron
turn into a titan wasn't crazy enough we
now know that there's another human-like
titan roaming around this opens the door
to a number of possibilities first there
might be a number of different people
that can turn into titans which is both
the scariest and most interesting news
that the human race has learned in the
past 100 years if that tells us anything
aaron's transformation wasn't a fluke he
is part of a very special group of
humans that has the potential to change
the landscape of the world now if i were
the scout regiment leader i'd be less
interested in hunting these titans down
and more interested in finding out how
the hell aaron managed to turn into a
titan and i would wonder if anyone else
not only in the group but in the city
would be able to pull off the same thing
just then another scout comes by with a
horse for armin and the duo meet another
member while they chase down this female
titan armin tells him that this monster
is part human and part titan and that he
thinks her goal isn't to eat people but
to find someone since she hasn't eaten
anybody that they've seen her kill and
so she must be the one who let the
titans in when the first wall fell the
team then figures out a new attack plan
to distract her from heading towards the
rear formation to prevent her from
finding eren or wiping out the rest of
the squad or both they need to buy time
so everybody can retreat the team
spreads out to cover the female titan
from both sides but this monster catches
on quick and swats armin away like a fly
knocking him off his horse but he thinks
fast and yells out that aaron's been
killed stopping the female titan from
killing this guy but just then this
other scout grapples onto her and flings
himself up into the sky until he gets
caught and he breaks out like a japanese
edward scissorhands and grabs armin and
heads off with this other dude while the
horrifying female titan goes in the
other direction probably straight for
aaron back near aaron's location he sees
a black smoke signal near him indicating
that there's an abnormal titan nearby
and it's not looking good as the female
titan continues to decimate small
squadrons of soldiers left and right
brutally killing them all destroying the
formation the female titan forces the
scouts to make a new plan and take a
position within this nearby forest to
intercept any titans that pass by here
including confronting the human titan
herself they cannot afford to retreat
just then aaron's squad enters the
forest but shit's already hit the fan
the human titan is right behind them
horrifyingly eyeing eren like a predator
to its prey quickly killing all rear
reinforcements like they are nothing
forcing captain levi and his squad to
keep aaron safe and continue pressing on
at top speed despite the horrors of
seeing their squad mates die uselessly
left and right suddenly a blast of a
thousand grappling hooks stop this titan
dead in her tracks trapping her while
aaron and his squad finally managed to
get away the scouts are gonna get a look
at whoever's inside of her one way or
another but this titan is a beast and
best every attempt the scouts make to
try and cut out the person hiding inside
of her and is about to get a whole lot
worse just then the female titan lets
out a raging roar calling all the titans
in the area being distracted by the
scouts to come save her the female titan
forces the regiment to think fast and
kill every single creature there cutting
off limbs heads and napes of necks but
it's no use the titans quickly overwhelm
the squad and begin to cannibalize the
female titan forcing the regiment to
withdraw and return to base but
something is not right as steen begins
to form around the gathering titans
meaning the person inside the titan has
a chance to escape but unlike aaron the
person inside the female titan is
able-bodied and more advanced and she
attacks the retreating forces killing
off scout members near aaron before
turning back into another female titan
the squad then tells aaron to go on
without them while they take on the
female titan this group of scouts is a
cut above the rest and decimate this
titan until they don't because this
female titan has some tricks up her
sleeve and eventually kills each and
every one of the scouts finest forcing a
scared and enraged aaron to swing back
and take up the mantle of titan killer
again transforming into the only thing
strong enough to kill a titan another
titan aaron does everything that he can
but he fails sadly outmatched and she
chops his titan head off and swallows
aaron home mikasa reaches them just in
time to see her family get taken away
from her again forcing her to dance with
death itself cutting this titan down to
its knees while captain levi swings in
and helps mikasa save eren from the
titan's mouth just in the nick of time
before running away and heading back to
the main city the operation has failed
with the scout regiment losing more than
just soldiers but losing friends as well
forcing the support of the scout
regiment over aaron to collapse causing
him to be handed back over to the
capital's custody but thanks to armin
and this guy's determined scout regiment
they realize who the female titan really
is turning out to be the very same
person who killed those titans used for
experiments and the same one who trained
with aaron and the 104th cadet corpse
the gang knows who the female titan is
and sets out with a plan to trap her
inside a nearby tunnel come morning the
next day finally arrives and they set
the plan in motion with armin asking his
dear old friend within the military
police annie leonhardt if she can help
them with aaron's escape and she eagerly
agrees with this group being led down
this eerily empty street until they
reach some stairs leading down to some
underground tunnels but something is not
right as annie feels something is off
and she realizes that they know that
she's the female titan and he then reads
to bite her finger until a bunch of
other people stop her and tie her up but
they're no match for her as she has a
secret ring that has a hidden blade in
it and once more turned into the
horrifying female titan she was on to
them from the start okay i love my
attack on titan crew as much as the next
guy but i need to point something out we
probably should have known that annie
was the female titan by looking at her
features because no one else in the
104th regiment has the same features
like she does and not even that there
were even more telltale signs that she
was no ordinary scout hindsight is 2020
but the way the female titan looked and
moved back in the forest was near
identical to annie not only that the
female titan did no harm to armin even
though he was completely helpless now
this is what i would do without telling
anyone else in the group i would take
this opportunity to strike as soon as
possible at any moment that she turns
her back we need to take her down and
subdue her and dare i say even kill her
because if we're fast enough we could
have avoided this city being destroyed
once again and there's too many things
that can go wrong she's way too
dangerous to take any chances the scout
should have either tried to capture her
or kill her like i would the minute they
found out the news they should have done
everything that they could do to make
this job easier on themselves and one of
the biggest parts would have been to
sedate her in some way rather than just
relying on brute force of a bunch of
people trying to capture her they should
have been way more cautious and should
have used everything at their disposal
to take her down armin mikasa and eren
then get trapped in the tunnel with the
female titan blocking both exits leaving
them trapped with no way out and to top
off the bad news aaron can't turn into a
titan choking at the last minute this
forces mikasa and armin to act as decoys
and split up to confuse the female titan
but to add even more bad news aaron gets
stepped on by the female titan crushing
him good and trapping him beneath some
rubble but this isn't over yet and armin
sure is [ __ ] knows it sneaking over to
trapped aaron as more and more scouts
and fighters scramble to the female
titans location but she is unstoppable
and knows all of their moves before they
make it if armin doesn't get aaron to
act fast they're all dead so armin with
nothing but his words breaks through to
aaron allowing aaron to regain his titan
abilities and turning him back into the
unstoppable beast that everyone fears a
titan ready to kill annie aaron now a
fully formed titan killing machine
attacks annie the female titan with more
veracity and madness than ever thought
possible swinging his fist with more raw
power than rocky swinging at raw meat
and smashes annie down forcing her to
take it up a notch and fight dirty
beating the crap out of aaron smashing
his head in dozens of times allowing her
to run off but this time something is
different within aaron and he's lost too
many good friends to let their deaths be
in vain forcing something within him to
unveil and unleash more fury than ever
before aaron then engulfs his titan body
with flames lighting up his eyes with an
electric blue glow and runs to chase
annie down annie overwhelmed by aaron's
ferocity proceeds to climb up the wall
allowing her to escape and return to
attack again but mikasa has other plans
and swings up with vengeance in her eyes
and cuts annie's fingers clean off
causing her to fall back down hard and
falling into what might as well be hell
itself aaron in titanform attacks annie
severing annie from her titan body
scooping her out like human ice cream
aaron is either ready to kill her or
hand her over but just then in a
last-ditch self-defense effort annie
encases herself in diamond rock just as
captain levi comes in swinging to save
aaron from his titan body annie is now
encased in this diamond shell and
they're unable to pry the secrets that
they desperately need to know from her
the city eventually hands off annie to
be under the scout regiment's care deep
underground and aaron gets off the hook
letting him and annie rest ensuring that
all of their titan secrets to remain
undiscovered for now
but what do you think let us know down
in the comments below what you like and
what you didn't like don't forget to
subscribe check out our playlist and
also give us a thumbs up and don't
forget to check out our social media